i've heard you say so many times that
you are a hopeless romantic and you
still believe in love you believe in
marriage so like cat you still believe
in all of those absolutely why wouldn't
i
jennifer lopez speaking her future into
existence
and now that she said yes to being mrs
ben affleck e.t is learning more about
the couple's upcoming wedding bash and
this
was my
wedding
changing area e.t was on the ground
where bennifer exchanged vows at las
vegas little white wedding chapel around
midnight i feel
so excited you look gorgeous
[Music]
getting married
jen's first look for the evening and
alexander mcqueen dressed straight from
one of her films and get this the dress
retails for over 5 thousand dollars and
is completely sold out the singer
changed into her second look to walk
down the aisle an off-the-shoulder
long-sleeved lace gown by zuhair murad
an eyewitness explains how it all went
down once she made it to the altar with
ben as they were reading each other's
vows they were very sweet they both were
emotional they cried to each other the
kids were right there behind them we've
learned the intimate ceremony wasn't a
complete surprise a source tells e.t jen
and ben's vegas wedding was totally
planned but also private to them it was
perfect and a dream come true it's just
a dream come true but et has learned
vegas was just the first celebration and
the couple is now planning a bigger
party for more guests quote they will
absolutely be having a bigger wedding
ceremony and celebration that includes
close relatives friends and loved ones
according to tmz the wedding will be
held at ben's property in georgia now
the big question who will snag an invite
of course that's up to the couple but we
think jlo's hustler's co-star kiki
palmer would absolutely tear up the
dance floor these are my sisters
i'm so happy jaylon nobody deserves
happiness more and jen's pal j balvin
whom she shared the super bowl stage
with in 2020 he'd bring the energy all
night she knows i love her she knows i
have a lot of respect for her so i just
wish her the best but before the couple
kicks wedding planning into high gear
jlo is already back to doing what she
does best
[Music]
yeah just hours after becoming mrs
affleck jen was still in vegas rocking
all black leaving a dance studio we
can't wait to see jlo pull out her
signature moves on the dance floor at
their big wedding maybe we'll even get
ben in on the action with their first
stance as husband and wife
[Music]